you guys had a bit of a head start on me
but hopefully you're coming up with a
solution and when you've got a linear
divisor like this right there's a word
actually that appeared in the exercise
we heard look at yesterday that some of
you asked about but not all that many of
you and it's what I don't know if we've
given a formal introduction to it but
it's a word nor am I going to write it
I'll write it up here it's a word that
means a lot of things in a lot of
different contexts who encountered this
in your exercise degree degree did you
see it in there so degree we're used to
that meeting something when you measure
your angles right but really degree just
means anything that you're measuring
which is why we can use it for measuring
temperature person well in this context
the thing that we're interested in
measuring is what kind of polynomial
have you got what what's the size of
this thing what's its magnitude it's the
biggest power that you can see in the
polynomial you've got so this guy P of X
it's got a degree of what's the highest
power that you can see there's a four so
that's a degree four polynomial when you
divide degree four by a degree one
unsurprisingly your answer ends up being
degree three right because this is just
index horse isn't it your degree reduces
by well whatever it was you divided by
okay so this is better
we're already we've made some progress
we've got this thing in here now which
is considerably simpler than what we
started with but we're not finished yet
are we right all we've done is like
we've checked off we've checked off one
of these ok I've still got three other
factors to find now at this point I'm
going to hand to you have a look at this
last number here right I can do the same
trick that I did before when I looked at
this and I was like hmm reckon it's
gonna be a three involved there right
this last number is one any guesses what
might be a nice factor to try out one or
negative one there's both going to be
pretty good guesses in fact between the
both of you again you can use your
calculator and I'd love you to test one
and a negative one also and see what you
get included that working there if you
find for example if you find that P of 1
equals 0 what are you gonna divide by on
your next line what's its gonna tell you
about the factors X minus 1 thank you
silly
if I got pair of negative one being zero
what would you divide by in this case X
plus one okay you have the two of you
have two calculators see how far you can
get this is the polynomial we're dealing
with now see if you can test out some
numbers between the two of you and
divide further okay off you go what have
we concluded I've seen this with bits
and pieces view every has been moved
around misses these heads as well I
asked you in a pair to test out P of 1
and P of negative 1 just a couple of
things before we talk about your results
okay there would be no problem if you
went back to this original guy and put
in 1 or put a negative 1 you should have
gotten some results out of that okay
however I will point out because we've
gone through this long division once and
the result we got out was this cubic
right it's kind of like ah now I'm just
dealing with this cubic this is the
thing I'm interested in right do you
remember yesterday we had a look at a
problem like this with the remainder
theorem and then at a certain point will
I did like ten lines of working and then
we got to some simultaneous equations I
can't remember what exactly they were
but something like this okay and then we
got to this point and then I don't know
I think these are probably not exactly
the equations that I gave you yesterday
but you could then say oh I've
transformed this more complicated
problem into this simpler version I can
now somewhat put to the side of my mind
that original problem and just work with
the simpler one it's exactly the same
thing that you can do right here right
you can kind of view this as all right
I'm launching off into a new problem
just like the original one so when
you're substituting one negative one if
you wanted you could substitute them
just into here and you would have gotten
if you got these which I think you did
right these are both actually true then
you get them also getting zero out of
this okay now once you then determine
that what does that mean well this tells
you you have X minus 1 as a factor and
what about this second one what is that
what is the factor theorem tell you from
this guy X plus 1 is also a factor right
do you like cool 2 for the price of one
we're not really for the price of one
for the price of 2 but you did at the
same time right now from here I just
want to point out a couple things I have
them over here on the right hand side
the board so just look closely because
worth having a look at right you had
some choices at this point because you
actually have to
if you wanted you could divide by each
one individually right just like we did
for this guy we divided it through X
minus three you can divide by this then
you can divide it by this but and you
totally know how to do this so if you're
willing to give it a go it's a bit
harder but it's shorter then you totally
can divide by both factors at once have
a look over here right now I put it over
here because it was sort of side working
for me but here is my cubic in here and
X minus 1 X plus 1 when you multiply
them together what do you get X minus 1
X plus 1 this is difference of squares
is an x squared minus 1 now if I want to
divide by that in one hit divide you by
a quadratic divisor just like before if
you've got no X terms see I've got no
X's in there you start to include that
right that's an important thing in your
division but have a look right compare
this to the first time you divided
through by X minus 3 okay that was many
many lines you were dealing with
something much more complicated this is
short alliance but it sort of takes
longer to do it and we don't do it very
frequently so maybe like I don't feel
comfortable dividing through by a
quadratic I'd rather not but it's worth
giving a go if you didn't do this and
you're working I'd encourage you to give
it a shot because you do need to know
how to divide through by these I get an
answer at the top do you see my question
up there what do you see is my question
over at the end 2x plus 1 so now I'm
ready to take this guy and factorized
further right I've got the X minus 3
hanging out the front there right I've
got the X minus 1 and the X plus 1 which
I divided by and then lastly my question
there 2x plus 1 okay
so this is what I've done I've worked
out all of the factors for P of X
without any like clues handed to me like
hey try dividing - you just worked it
out together
but this thing is actually in the
original question it's actually equal to
0 now you can sort of hopefully see what
was the point of us going through all of
that effort to divide multiple times
right it's all in nice factorized form
so hopefully with me you can just read
off what are the values of x that I can
put in here
make the whole thing equal to zero well
slow down slow down I get negative one
from this fact up I get x equals three
from this factor that's x equals one and
then the last one yeah negative four
solutions for a polynomial of degree 4
hmm so this is what we've done right now
I would like you to have a go at 2 3 & 4
again don't just randomly try things
when you're using the fact that you have
a look at that number down the end it
gives you clues as to what numbers you
should try and you can do it together
I'm happy for you to do that okay
just one last note before I let you
loose on those some of you the student
among you might have noticed on the
right hand side board next to where I
divided by that quadratic thing I've got
this and some of you might look at that
and think what what is that okay now
this is just the same long division that
you're doing it was actually what I was
doing to check your answers out of this
okay it's another form of division
called synthetic division and you can
see it's got all the same numbers in it
if you compare my green working on the
left there to the long division you did
to get this answer hopefully all of the
numbers that I've written here you
actually see in your working but what
I've not written is all the X's okay now
if that was attracted to you I would
like to do this faster than the way I'm
doing it now
then what you have to show me is you can
master the long division we've showed
you at the beginning if you're like I'm
comfortable this really good at this I
can do it and very reliably not get any
errors with any minus signs or anything
like that then at that point once you've
mastered that method then you are ready
for me to show you this other method but
not before and if you never get to that
it's fine you have long division it
works just fine it's just long however
if you get to the point where you like
no I'm doing this I totally get it I
don't make any mistakes when I give
these a go in my exercises they'd call
me over and I can show you this other
method as an alternative not a
replacement but as an additional method
okay